tu fais preuve le divorce agence arrière
et je suis pour divorcer encore la
contraception
bah moi de toute façon j'ai perdu un
enfant comme ça
et la contraception ça existait pas b
mais j'ai toujours regretté tu penses
que sur le leader mais c'est parce que
je savais que je pouvais garder mais à
ce moment là tu c'était bon de se
rappeler du conservatoire rien ou aux
marques avec la mère que j'ai j'aurais
pu lui dire en face je lui ai dit après
c'est trop tard et je regrette tout la
sens pourquoi quelquefois toi ma fille
c'était pas prévu le petit garçon
tempête et puis elle m'a dit moi je suis
enceinte
je lui ai dit écoute tu gardes je peux
pas expliquer pourquoi parce que j'ai eu
d'avis comme ça qu'il avait fait et je
suis dit je t'en supplie garde le parce
que fidèle au stand info c'est pas toi
qui le décide c'est pareil les gens qui
me disent à des pigeons jamais d'enfant
et roland faut c'est décidé ils vont
arriver
donc je pense que moi je regrette ça
pour moi à ce moment là si j'avais le
g22 une possibilité est de savoir ça
parce que je savais pas ensemble et se
dire que vous ayez bien c'est un miracle
continue et il faut garder à ce qu'il y
ait une raison profonde et saint gillois
complètement et il n'a pas le droit
d'arrêter c'est que ça voilà c'est
possible le togo situé favorable oui
pour le coup pas enlever mais ça va pas
le faire demain
abbas à elle est partie celle là
j'espère qu'à part on va dire tout haut
on dit tu crois que tu conduis même si
tu l'appelles pas dieu il faut croire
quelque chose parce que marié alors ça
veut dire qu'ils étaient dans le désert
tu es dans le vide tient sur le pool de
tout à l'heure et puis tu plonges
pourquoi pas ou que tu peux t'en je vais
insister si t'es pas tenus par des des
règles et des reines des choses
quelquefois bois c'est un souhait que
quelqu'un sait séduire émissions aux
amoureux lot de du plaisir je suis
heureux de vivre tu as rose comptant
alors voilà je suis bien mais nous aussi
au lieu des 13 autres et pour être sûr
de ne rien rater de winne a l'habitude
abonnez vous mettez un pouce bleus